Nous sommes pour
l'instoration d'une exception agriculturelle.
Nous demandons à ce que l'agriculture
et bien soit sortie des traités de libre-échange.
La vraie réponse
européenne au défi migratoire,
c'est le pacte à l'immigration.
Si vous,
si vous allez chercher les clandestins en bateau,
vous les ramenez sur les frontières France européenne,
vous voudrez participer,
vous croyez qu'il va se passer quoi ?
Il va y avoir 1 appel d'air considérable.
Ce que vous proposez, c'est le chaos.
Et votre
obsession
sur l'immigration 0, c'est le chaos qui a 1 forme de
de légèreté,
de désinvolture de la part d'Emmanuel Macron.
On a l'impression
qu'il joue à la guerre comme au Playmobil.
1 décollistière de madame aubrey d'ailleurs,
explique que le Hamas c'est 1
1, 1 orgasme légitime, hein, dans ce
dans sa, dans sa résistance,
madame Rima Hassan pour ne pas la citer,
et donc souvenez-vous à l'époque,
oui, nous défendons le droit international.
On est dans des débats de posture,
on s'injective, on s'apostrophe et cetera.
Quelle image renvoyons nous nous de nous là aujourd'hui,
quel image renvoyons-nous de ce débat ?
Il faut pas s'étonner que les français
s'écartent de la politique
et s'éloignent de la politique
lorsqu'on s'injective de la sorte.
L'Europe n'est pas aujourd'hui
directement menacé.
Vous avez pris de l'argent, monsieur Poutine,
monsieur Mariani,
faites attention, si vous faites des accusations,
monsieur, c'est 1 accusation ou c'est 1 question,
c'est 1 question.
Alors vous connaissez la réponse ? Dites-nous
mes relations avec Poutine, excusez-moi,
elles sont certainement moins.
Fréquentes que celles de monsieur Macron,
c'est ce mandat. A. P.
A, ce qui me choque,
c'est que vous étiez
parti en crimé pour reconnaître l'annexion de la crimé.
C'est pour ça que vous êtes
sanctionnés par le parlement en revient,
vous connaissez ?
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai hésité, moi,
à venir ce soir se retrouver
face aux petits télégraphistes du Kremlin
qui votent contre
les condamnations de Wagner,
où vous avez servi la soupe à ce régime,
mais pas seulement à celui-là.
Vous êtes 1 patriote de pas petit,
comme les gens de votre mouvement,
comme vous alliez ici,
qui défendait 1 tyrannie étrangère.
Quand l'endroit c'est fini,
sur la table, 1 plan de
reconstruction de la
production énergétique qui s'appelait RIP hour you.
J'ai déposé 1 amendement
pour que le nucléaire puisse
bénéficier de ces deux-cent-dix milliards.